[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
Hoy les proponemos descubrir Las
aventuras de un explorador un explorador
del siglo XXI que acaba de recorrer00 km
donde nace La cordillera de los Andes en
Venezuela y lo ha hecho en bicicleta se
trata del ciclista francés y fundador
del Campeonato de Ultra ciclismo viking
Man Hoy hace escala en París Axel cajeó
Muchísimas gracias Axel por estar con
nosotros Gracias bueno Axel que es
originario de sharp a unos 100
kilómetros de París y desde hace más de
una década 11 años comentaba antes
práctica el ciclismo de larga distancia
y de exploración lo que le ha llevado a
recorrer miles y miles de kilómetros por
zonas como Europa central los balcanes
el Atlas marroquí y en 2015 recorren
bicicleta 13.500 km En Los Andes desde
Cartagena en Colombia hasta Us en
Argentina y de esa experiencia luego
crea ese campeonato el viking man que es
el primer campeonato de carrera de Ultra
ciclismo en autonomía total un
campeonato que le ha llevado ha llevado
a cabo ya en países como omán Francia
Brasil Perú Portugal laos o Taiwán
primero de todo Axel Qué es el
ultraciclismo y el bikepacking Pues el
Ultra ciclismo es un modo de andar larga
distancia con una bicicleta al menos 200
kilómetros al día y el bikepacking es un
modo de traer maletas livianas sobre una
bicicleta para hacer como sin asistencia
y traer comida bebida y ropa para
ahondar larga distancia claro ser
autónomo no para poder correr durante
muchos kilómetros y participa mucha
gente en el viking man pues desde la
creación del Campeonato en 2016 hasta
hoy tenemos más de dos mil atletas en
total y ahora cada estación cada no
tenemos mil atletas que se unen al
campeonato Bueno ya lo recibimos hace
unos años en el programa para hablarnos
del camino de los incas y hoy vamos a
hablar de otra Aventura La última que ha
hecho usted ha sido En Los Andes que
conoce muy bien lo decíamos en la
presentación Pero esta vez en un lugar
que no conocía son los Andes de
Venezuela un recorrido de 1000
kilómetros en cinco días que comenzó en
acarigua porque ha elegido Venezuela
Pues gracias a un amigo que se llama
Daniel acoso mondo un saludo al amigo
venezolano que participaba el Campeonato
viking Bad en 2021 y que me compartí la
idea de venir a Venezuela a descubrir
los hombres porque no conocía que los
Andes nacen en Venezuela pensaba que
pues era en Colombia O tal vez en
Ecuador y desde este sueño 2021
trabajamos juntos para organizar esta
expedición la preparación es muy dura
Supongo que la ayuda de la gente local
no como me comentaba David es
imprescindible para hacer el trazado
porque supongo que no es fácil además en
un clima tropical como es una parte de
Venezuela subir a una altitud no de
4.000 metros o más incluso Sí claro en
esta expedición tenemos una altura hasta
más de 4000 con el alto del collado del
cóndor Y pues también disfrutamos de la
experiencia de Daniel y de sus amigos
que se llaman que es como una compañía
que tienen bastante experiencia en
autismo Y tenemos buenas ondas de este
grupo gracias a Daniel Alfredo y a tío
para organizar este recorrido juntos y
asegurar que todo va a salir bien para
este tipo de expedición que son muy muy
salvajes con el tema del cuerpo y de la
altura claro las condiciones son muy
duras No porque buena parte de físico o
sea la temperatura en Venezuela tal vez
no No fue fácil cambiar de muchos grados
a pocos grados si es la unas de las
diferencias muy importantes de la de los
Andes venezolanos es que hay eso ondes
tropicales y que hay como temperatura
desde 40 grados por los ciudadanos por
ejemplo donde es muy plano hasta la
altura del collado del cóndor donde
tenemos casi cero grados entonces hay
una variedad muy importante de
temperatura que tiene que manejar con la
ropa que cargamos sobre la bicicleta y
Tenemos también que superar con el
cuerpo a este tipo de desafío y
obviamente Venezuela para mí es como una
experiencia
un poquito diferente de Perú por ejemplo
porque hay el calor y el frío que pues
es muy difícil a manejar con el tema del
cuerpo esa diría que es la
particularidad que tiene
para un ciclista los Andes venezolanos
es esa o hay otras particularidades en
comparación para mí yo conozco bien
Ahora los Andes desde Colombia hasta
Argentina obviamente la parte muy
simbólica de Venezuela son la parte
Tropical y que hay
al nivel del mar y arriba de los Andes
con una diferencia total de paisajes y
de experiencia de andar en bicicleta
también nos los pueblos las personas que
encontramos los venezolanos son muy
diferentes también y me encanta de andar
alta altura y en las montañas porque se
puede ver cómo viven las personas y allá
era como lo que me encantó en las
montañas de los Andes como la amistad y
también el el son bienvenidos Cuando
llegamos En Bicicleta cada vez que
estuvimos allá Es una experiencia muy
muy importante para el corazón
lo comentábamos al principio pero claro
Ustedes han conocido a mucha gente
porque llevan las bolsas en las
bicicletas
pero también tienen que parar no a
repostar Cómo es el reabastecimiento
digamos es fácil es difícil porque
tenemos que buscar comida bebida y
también alojarnos en lugares que no son
como acostumbrados a tener como turistas
en bicicleta pero es una parte de la
experiencia también y todavía sobre esta
expedición en Venezuela no tenemos
muchos problemas al revés tenemos muchas
personas que quisieran ayudarnos a
hospedarnos a encontrar comida porque no
están acostumbrados a tener turistas por
allá y Pero son muy felices de tener
turistas que viajan con bicicleta y que
hacen el deporte y
ahondar en este tipo de lugar que son
muy salvajes en bicicleta son felices
cómo estaban los precios porque uno
Venezuela es un país en crisis hay
millones de personas que han tenido que
abandonar el país qué percepción
tuvo usted y su equipo creo que cinco
personas las que iban en bicicleta qué
percepción tuvieron los precios estaban
caros para mí hay dos mundos hay el
mundo de Caracas y hay un mundo de En
Los Andes en Caracas claro el nivel de
vida es caro con el tema del dólar
también pero cuando salimos de la
capital y que llegamos En Los Andes es
mucho mejor mucho más fácil encontrar
comida barata y también a hospedaje
barato hay dos mundos es caro en general
hacer este tipo de expediciones en bici
habla un general se necesita un
presupuesto
puede el más caro es de llegar al país
es de ligar con el avión pero desde que
eras en el país no es tan caro porque
manejamos casi todo
auto auspiciado y buscamos comida de
calle y pues hospedaje que encontramos
durante el viaje entonces no es tan caro
para gente que no se esté escuchando y
viendo qué consejos le daría un ciclista
que quisiera aventurarse En Los Andes
venezolanos Pues es de primero aprender
la decisión de ir porque es un país
virgen para mí de exploración en
bicicleta y hay venezolanos que le
esperan porque están felices de
encontrar ciclistas que van a explorar
el país
prender la decisión de ir y después todo
va a salir bien porque es un país
espectacular por varios pues buenos
puntos que no tenemos el tiempo de
compartir pero la cultura el calor el
clima los paisajes las personas para mí
era como una exploración muy muy buena
para el corazón
y a nivel técnico algún consejo en
particular
Pues de yo puedo compartirla los
contactos de los amigos de ecoris que
son los primeros ultraciclistas
venezolanos que organizan como tour y
también consejos para atraer personas en
el país a explorar el país son muy
orgullosos también de Venezuela conocen
las frutas conocen los caminos en gravel
entonces tiene que ponerte en contacto
con eco aiders y danielmabu polacos para
ver si pueden también ayudar a organizar
su propio viaje allá van a organizar un
viking Man en Venezuela es un sueño
ahora trabajamos juntos a Daniel y
también y por ahí dos para traer una
etapa del campeón de tu puñal a
Venezuela es un sueño porque
viking Man así En Los Andes en Perú
ahora no podemos ir a Perú con el tema
político pero es un sueño de regresar en
el son de si tal vez en Venezuela
considera que América del Sur se ha
convertido en una especie de del Dorado
para el Ultra ciclismo y el bikepacking
para mí una sí En Los Andes Porque allá
nací la idea del viking Man así también
muchas cosas muchas buenas ondas que yo
tenía de este viaje dos veces a cruzar
cruda de Sudamérica pienso que hay algo
en estas montañas que que es especial
Tiene que ir porque hay un momento antes
de cruzar los Andes y hay un momento
después y pienso que es un paraíso a
explorar en bicicleta cierto hablábamos
antes de bueno esa comunidad de venezo
que se está creando se ha creado en
torno al Ultra ciclismo
se está desarrollando a nivel de
latinoamérica o Sudamérica una comunidad
de ciclistas
de en este sector digamos de la bici
extrema claro la el tema del
ultraciclismo de andar larga distancia y
también dentro de él está creciendo
mucho en Sudamérica porque hay un
terreno espectacular en Colombia en
Chile en Brasil también porque
organizamos hace dos años una etapa del
imán en Brasil y ahora también
trabajamos con la comunidad venezolana
para mí es un sueño también de crecer el
movimiento del ultraciclismo porque los
atletas allá tienen bastante
ingredientes para crecer como potencial
importante de personas que tienen
bastante fuerza Así que hay altura
montañas muy salvajes condiciones
ahondar que sean difícil y que son mucho
más difícil que en Europa ahora los
Estados Unidos por ejemplo y sale como
una suerte para ellos si quieren
competir por ejemplo en Europa o los
Estados Unidos porque tienen un terreno
muy duro pero que sale bien para tener
una experiencia especial
quería preguntarle también Que bueno hay
países que son muy conocidos por la
tradición ciclista como Colombia
Venezuela tal vez lo sea menos igual es
una idea equivocada que tenemos no sé
qué percepción tuvo usted en Venezuela
Pues para mí tengo una percepción de
Daniel que es un pasionista de montaña
de un pasionista de andinismo y hay una
cultura de ahondar en montaña importante
en Venezuela porque hay montañas
importantes y es un traslado fácil a
hacer entre el ninismo de andar en
montaña y el ultraciclismo que es un
modo de ahondar pero con la bicicleta es
más fácil entonces creo que hay un
potencial importante en Venezuela pues
muchísimas gracias Axel por haber
estado con nosotros y haber compartido
con nosotros sus experiencias y deseamos
que siga recorriendo y descubriendo
miles de kilómetros Muchas gracias
gracias y gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que también
nos pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]